another day closer to Avengers infinity
war and I am still freaking out over
here on this segment of where the
Avengers are currently at in the MCU
we'll be welcoming some new heroes to
the Avengers and there's some of my
personal favorite heroes and movies and
that is a great hero named Kevin Bacon
that's right today we will be talking
about the guardians of the galaxy
finally and why the Avengers need them
if they want to have any chance at
defeating Thanos before we get started
don't let this channel go over your head
and please subscribe to stay up to date
on Avengers infinity war nothing goes
over my head my reflexes are too fast if
you have not seen one or both of the
movies about this group of misfits I
highly encourage you to turn away also
if you do not want any potential
spoilers about Avengers in Fonua I would
also turn away because we may speculate
a little bit and I'm not sure if I can
predict the future but we will find out
on April 27th the guardians of the
galaxy our favorite group of misfits
they've not only saved the galaxy once
but two times first time from Ronan and
the second time from ego star Lords
father they're not the most glorious set
of heroes but they do get the job done
in their own way this plan tears I think
it's good except it sucks so let me do
the plan and that way it might be really
good wow the guardians that we'll be
seeing on screen in infinity war it will
be Peter quill aka star-lord Rocket
Raccoon Gamora teen group Drax the
destroyer mantis and she's kind of an
Avenger right now but also not really
but also very important to Avengers
infinity war and that is nebula the
Avengers we'll need the guardians of the
galaxy in the fight against Thanos
because they bring something very
crucial and specific to infinity war
what are you doing dance-off fro me and
you
but if a dance-off doesn't work which is
very unlikely I'm sure they'll defeat
Thanos they have Gamora and nebula
Gamora and nebula are technically the
adopted daughters of Thanos if I adopted
them you mean he murdered their families
kidnapped them and then raised them to
be killing machines yeah he adopted them
but the main point here being that he
raised them and trained them and
enhanced them to be superhumans
essentially and to be ultimate weapons
they fought for Thanos and they've sat
by his side and watched him as he's
fought and taken over worlds they know
how he fights they know his weaknesses
they know his strategies we can already
see from the trailers that Gamora has a
ton of information on Thanos the
Avengers are going to have to seriously
team up with Gamora if they want to know
how to defeat Thanos and even though
nebula left the guardians of the galaxy
to pursue killing Thanos herself we know
from the trailers that she shows up to
help them fight another big reason the
Avengers need the guardians of the
galaxy in the fight against Thanos is
because in the comics Gamora nebula and
Drax actually defeat Thanos Drax
surprisingly and amazingly punches
Thanos heart out of his chest
nebula manages to get her hands on the
Infinity Gauntlet and wipes him away
from existence but the really cool part
about how Gamora defeats stano's is that
she has helped from Adam warlock this
makes me wonder how and when Adam
warlock will enter the MCU in the
post-credits scenes of guardians of the
galaxy volume 2 we are introduced to
Adam warlocks cocoon we have been told
that Adam warlock won't make his
appearance until guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 but this could just be to throw us
off the Russo brothers recently came out
and said that fans have no idea what the
plot of Avengers infinity war would be
we also realized that the main lineup of
Avengers that they have for an affinity
war right now none of them could
probably defeat Thanos so there is a
need to bring in new characters such as
Captain Marvel and Adam warlock let's
also not forget that star-lord is half
celestial being his mother was a human
on earth but his father was ego the
celestial in guardians of the galaxy vol
2 when they defeated ego apparently
Peter Quill's abilities went away but he
still has celestial DNA inside of him I
wouldn't be surprised if he somehow
manages to tap back into his powers and
who knows maybe he can even willed an
infinity
stoned by himself and let's not forget
rocket and teen group teaming up with
Thor we're not quite sure why the two of
them break off and go with Thor but it
is clear that they play a crucial role
in helping Thor make his new hammer
Stormbreaker and of course the guardians
of the galaxy as a team are known to
cause chaos and destruction and the best
way to whoever they go against but will
the guardians of the galaxy be enough to
help the Avengers defeat Thanos what do
you guys think let me know what you guys
think in the comments below and be sure
to like this page and be a princess and
subscribe to my channel and join the
wolf wolf pack I am NOT a pizza thank
you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you